good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it's another beautiful
Tuesday in New York City it seems like
the longer quarantine goes on the
weather just refuses to be anything but
beautiful hey Claude hyd oh my god I'm
feeling so good like the small pit I had
about hearing how you're durn was just
totally subsided with a a small dose of
hyd well you know what like I guess we
feel the two ways that people feel about
hyd like I love it I think it brightens
my day I love saying it it just like
gives me a burst of energy and there's a
lot of people who feel that way and then
there's obviously the people who are
triggered and I think that we represent
both of those people now today I hate
with you with an hyd because we're
already having a rough morning we're not
gonna go into it but um it's just
torture just notice her totally um and
for those watching on YouTube you might
not recognize me because I've been
looking like a hermit for the last two
months and now I've decided to do a full
face of makeup and hair and I thought
that it would make me feel better like
you know they say like you look how you
feel and I actually don't feel better I
feel really stupid
[Music]
you
and she's frozen so I don't know how
that's gonna play out when this you know
just frozen okay cool let's hope that
that sounded okay whatever let's just
move on if it happens again we'll start
over but for sure that's actually never
happened to us so far yet so that's a
new sensation um welcome to day 1,050 of
the quarantine today actually is a great
day because it's our first time doing
the show being able to tell people that
we are
auntie's oh yeah oh it was a long
weekend and so much happened you can
call me aunt Vicki Olivia our wonderful
smart beautiful stunning older sister
gave birth to her daughter Mikayla
ostrich hero and it has just been a
whirlwind of emotion so she gave birth
on Friday morning um
and mom is good everyone's good it's
just truly like life is so different
life is so different it's such a crazy
time it's a crazy time to be in the
hospital to give birth to have a baby in
the niku and so we're just shucking and
driving and we're just so excited for
the baby
michaei we love her so much she's over
getting cute I can't and I show [ __ ]
cute you guys like so little and perfect
and it's like she just has everything
you know she has knuckles and hair it's
crazy nails yeah can't wait I can't wait
to paint um yeah I'll do a plea knee
vibe
she's so cute Olivia is finally home I'm
so happy for Olivia I like to be home
after like almost a month in the
hospital I'm just it's like it's
happening you know it's happening I'm
I'm just so excited to eventually meet
her meet little baby and it's just it's
a really great time so thank you to
everyone who is so sent well wishes to
our family sent well wishes to Olivia
means so much and we're just we're over
the moon so even though we had our daily
dose of torture this morning we are
generally speaking over the moon over
the moon ot M as I like to say um and I
I just came ready you know like I
watched so much TV that um I cannot wait
to dive into an hour TV recap segment
and of course
you know deliver the past five because
what else am i doing right
I watched you the amount of TV and I
read a lot and I woke up so early this
morning I went to sleep last night
at like a 45 and I woke up this morning
at 7:30 which if you know me you know
that that just does not happen ever even
if I go to see that a 45 like okay I'll
still wake up at 11 um but I just like
got up I was gonna do my hair I put on
some self-tanner and I've had a a
morning already and I just want to say
like I feel pretty much the same I just
feel like weird I feel like any time I
wake up early I'm just anxious cuz I
feel like I'm going to the airport yeah
my problem with waking up early is that
the days are so long in quarantine
normally when you're waking up early
you're giving yourself more hours to
fill and I already have a hard time like
filling the 12 hours that I spend awake
in quarantine like I cannot wake up a
minute sooner because I have nothing to
do yeah oh so I don't know about you but
just like being a person who's
quarantined in New York City this
weekend and then like going on Instagram
and stuff like I feel like I'm living on
a different [ __ ] planet then everyone
else in this world I actually can no
longer go on Instagram and Instagram
stories because it is triggering for me
because everyone like I things are
opening up people are doing things yes
they're socially distant but they're
seeing each other there are beaches
there at pools they're out of state
they're in second homes and I just feel
like I'm living in an alternate universe
like in this New York City cage and if
you're quarantined in the city then you
know and unless you're in the city you
don't no no we are so like lightning
years behind other states like for for
an example like only today are like
certain more remote parts of New York
starting phase one like we are so not
even close to the end here in New York
City so just know like if you've ever
felt like I can't wait to meet in New
York City follow my dreams it can't move
no that's not a thing don't ever move
here stay in your low income tax state
because I'm coming after all this I'm
coming and I'm so happy for like the
rest of the state that's getting to open
you know um but just being in this city
like it just feels like we're kids in
the playground and the teachers left and
there's no one in charge there's no any
charge there's no one
to tell us that like recess is over get
back to class like no one no one is
looking out for us I feel like we've
been forgotten about everyone else is
taking steps forward phase one phase two
you know making strides we have been
forgotten
no we've totally been forgotten I never
thought I would like what my teacher
back but I need her or him like please
come save me please gonna save me like
it's too much recess no I've had enough
I have been recessed and now we're in a
recession literally literally oh my god
get me the [ __ ] out of here like I'm
done
I just I've never felt more there's just
you know what it is there are two types
of people in this world okay we'll have
second homes and people who don't and
it's never been more apparent like the
difference between the two people like I
don't have a second home and I just feel
like so resentful of the people who do
you know right but then there's also
people who might not have a second home
but have like siblings or cousins out of
state and they're just like you know
staying with family you know family
lives right here no totally like I feel
you 100% like there are people or it
also depends on where you live there are
just certain areas that are close to or
nearby it's like a lot of like bang in
cities like and the more I think about
it like New York is near nothing like
the places we can go our Atlantic City
the Hamptons the Jersey Shore like none
of those are really calling my name
right now no but those are actually
decent options in I guess everyone has
their like sure you know you could like
I just can go to Myrtle Beach right so
I've been feeling like my next stop on
the life Express is South Carolina like
I need to be on the beach near the OBX
like I'm just going to the Carolinas and
then I could sing like all about the
Carolinas in those country songs ya know
I'm so so here for that um I'm with you
whenever you want to like put your foot
on the gas didn't get out of the city I
just need someone to drive me okay I can
put my foot on the gas and physically
drive you there so that's what's new
with us I hope everyone had a great
Memorial Day weekend oh yeah oh my god
it was like the most torturous Memorial
Day weekend because I was getting my
time hop from last year when we were all
at camp toast being
ulis and not knowing that like the end
was upon us we just we were so naive
back then and I just missed that
ignorance you know we were so naive like
giving hugs sharing Jules just secrete
oh my god yes we were like we honestly
probably started coded because we were
like slobbering all over each other for
three days straight ya know we built up
our immune systems for this time it was
just such a good time and I I remember
feeling so ugly but when I look back on
the pictures I looked so cute like I had
just learned how to curl my hair
properly and I just was like looking so
fabulous and I was wearing my Dino felis
sneakers all around like stomping around
camp toast and I just I miss her like I
I didn't I don't even know if I fully
appreciated like how special it was to
be one with nature and now that I've
literally not left the confines of my
bedroom for last three months
I just I'm I took that for granted ya
know we all took a lot of things for
granted and now we're stuck yeah I think
of anything I the most the thing I most
took for granted was restaurants yeah I
keep thinking like what is it that I
miss so much like I could well like it's
just something I even miss meetings
meetings meetings meetings like yeah
just miss having places to go and people
to see like I am just in my little cage
and it's it's wild well I was having a
conversation with someone yesterday
about this and I think I really hit the
nail on the head if I do say so myself
it's like why people who are quarantine
quarantined in New York are a having
such a hard time be like statistically
there like so many people are gonna move
out of New York probably because it's
terrible and also because after all this
is done the tax is gonna go up so high
and we're already such a high income
state income tax state but I think I
really hit the nail on the head and like
why New Yorkers in particular are having
such a hard time and it's because when
we all moved to New York like of course
there's terrible things about living in
New York expensive small apartments
overrun by rats but like the life and
the bustle and the hustle and the
everything about New York like it made
you forget it's like who needs an
apartment we're out eating Chinese food
at 4:00 in the morning I don't even need
an apartment you know no it's a I'm not
getting an apartment so I can live in it
like it's just a place to sleep in
between going to all these fabulous
places so now that all the hustle-bustle
fabulousness has ended we are left with
what we have
what we have in New York is very little
like compared to what you have in you
know Nashville or Florida like it's just
you are now left like the city is
irrelevant like you're just left with
what you have and most people like when
they are renting or buying an apartment
in New York they always value location
over space like you could get a very big
apartment when I'm very big like a
bigger apartment uptown for the same
amount of money I was like a smaller
city apart of bahara in downtown but
downtown is worth like this so everyone
took those apartment downtown's just so
they could you know have the life and
now it's like there's no life and you're
in your small apartment location
location location means nothing when
there's no car to go I like not to brag
have always been the type of person who
values space over location always and
I'm so glad I made that decision because
if I had chosen location I would be in a
smaller apartment than I am now
yeah I just wish I had also valued
Terrace yes because yes like it's just
such a production to go outside the
masks and the gloves and then you're
like have to be in the street like if I
could just like walk outside get some
fresh air like I go three days without
breathing fresh air and I just I don't
know much I'm not a scientist but I just
know that can't be good for me yeah and
you know what the way you're describing
like that's sort of like like that
procedure that's involved with going
outside reminds me of 10 our word of the
day today oh wow that's so exciting
please share its homonymous meaning
ambiguous having the same designation of
or relating to being homonyms so it's
just like every day in quarantine is
quite home ominous so I feel like
merriam-webster shows that like
intentionally today yeah she's like a
shady one yeah her Twitter's out of
control yeah no I appreciate it though
um anyway so if you are not in New York
like congratulations to you I hope you
know you're getting your nails done and
your roots and things are happening for
you um actually did my nails this
morning that's how much that's how much
time I had this morning I did a full new
manicure they're very cute my nails are
just the healthiest they've ever been
well that's that's good
okay well let's get right into it yet we
actually have a lot to talk about today
um so I think let's jump right in you
sure to what the fast sized stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast Oh
and that's true Jackie but while you're
feeling hid I'm feeling RDH because I
want to let everyone know that today's
episode is brought to you by Hunter
Killer take advantage of time spent
inside at home whether alone or with
others and breakout Hunter Killer we can
only watch TV and scroll on our phone so
many nights in a row
so this murder mystery game is the best
way to switch things up Hunter Killer
reinvents the way we interact with
murder mysteries you can go proof from
being a viewer safe in the comfort of
your own home to an investigator
actively involved in solving a case the
latest season starts with a woman Julia
who on earth the corpse of a famous
actress from the 30s in her family's
theatre with the Board of Directors
trying to push Julia out and the
theaters reputation on the line you will
have to help solve this cold case
investigation before it's too late
with each delivery you'll sift through
piles of documents evidence for audio
recordings and Case Files eliminating
suspects until you crack the case it
brings the fun of an escape room to your
home it's easy to play whether you're
solo or with family you can even join
their spoiler-free online community with
over a hundred thousand members so you
can share theories and help each other
out along the way Hunter Killer has over
two thousand five star reviews.i
Trustpilot it's a no wonder why people
love them so much
plus part of the proceeds from every box
go to the Cold Case Foundation an
organization that is dedicated to
helping with the real-life cold cases so
I love a game night whether it's in
quarantine or out of quarantine and
Hunter Killer is just like a fresh new
vibe that like you get new shipments it
just it never ends it's not like you
know everyone goes home and the game's
over no the game stays with you yeah
right now just for our listeners you can
go to Hunter Killer dot-com slash toast
and use promo code toast a check out for
20% off your first box head to hunt a
killer dot-com slash toast for 20% off
to show your support for our podcast
Hunter Killer dot-com slash toast
thank you home tequila for sponsoring
today's episode love it
sign-on Hunter Killer okay yes first
story the big story of the weekend
Alex Cooper has spoken Friday night she
dropped like a 30 minute video 9 p.m. we
were all there ready willing and able
explaining her side her and Sophia side
until they split but
their side of what's been going on with
the color daddy negotiations she did a
really great job of explaining herself
and the moral of the story is that she's
gonna see you [ __ ] on Wednesday
because she is now going to host the
podcast without Sophia Franklin so
before we dive into the semantics I have
to say like what a well done video like
I love that she came with an ally she
came with notes because when you're
going through like a big scandal and you
can't really speak on things it is
infuriating to see people in reddit
groups Facebook groups like speaking on
your name as if they know everything
like as it's a matter of fact they're
like well I have a friend whose sisters
friend Alex and she said Alex play it
like you don't [ __ ] know anything and
it's infuriating to see misinformation
be spread about you and like no one
questions it so I love that she just
like attacked every [ __ ] rumor
because it's infuriating to be in that
position and I totally respected that I
thought it was such a well done video
and it really cemented for me like what
I thought before like everyone in this
situation did what they thought was
right whether or not V I'll agree but
that like they all had their own motives
so whether it was get back to barstool
get away from barstool or Dave keep this
show a parcel like he was very amenable
in the negotiations which was shocking
like I feel now stronger more than ever
everyone just had different goals and
everybody was doing what they thought
was best for themselves right no one
like lost their mind when crazy got so
greedy we'll talk about like the I think
the most interesting part which is like
where her and Sophia really differed and
how really now at the end of the day
like they are not coming back together
which I just think is so crazy I can't
believe we're in this place but I also
understand it based on everything that
she said um and I thought I agree with
you I thought the video was completely
well down I'm not left with really
questions on her side
I of course I'm left with questions on
Sophia's side and I would love for her
to make a similar video and I just don't
think we're gonna get that from her I
don't know why but I just feel like
we're not I agree I feel the same
sentiment part of me feels like she has
just kind of given up yeah me too I mean
if she doesn't want to get back into
this business and she doesn't need to
make a video but if she like wants to be
in the public arena then she needs to do
public image work
yeah like PR um but let's talk about
some of the semantics because what I
found to be most interesting
and I think maybe was the the reason for
the whole divide is that when their
renegotiation and so by the way people
were um were coming at us last week for
us saying that like they're breaking
their contract they're just like an
athlete you can't
and it's like no actually islets cleared
it up in the video they were up for
renegotiation it was time to negotiate
they didn't just decide one day like we
want more money like it was time yeah
well their contract wasn't up but they
had the opportunity to renegotiate him
when they came initially back in the
fall with their Peter Nelson's term
sheets that were absurd they still
should have gotten a raise and I do
think I understand like Dave is running
a business like it is not a charity and
if he can get away with paying these
girls lessen industry-standard he is
going to but like they deserve to raise
at that point and if they had gotten
that raise like I don't think this would
have gotten so bad but like for everyone
and especially for like Sophia and Peter
who yes I know that like he is the
villain of the story but he is in the
industry and he does see that his
girlfriend hosts the number two podcast
in the world and is making a base before
she hits her job out of the park a base
of $75,000 a year it's a joke and even
Alex you dress that like everybody in
the sports world like knew that their
contract was a joke right so at the end
of the day I feel like what it all
really came down to is that Alex wanted
to stay up our stool from the beginning
and Sophia kind of went into this whole
thing just not interested in continuing
with parcel for whatever reason whether
it was money or whether it was just like
she didn't like yeah yeah it's all for
everyone no I agree Alex wanted to make
it work with barstool and Sophia got a
taste of freedom and she wanted to ride
that wave now I want to ask you
something so I was talking about this
was Zach on Friday night because he
watched the video and he asked me what
would you have done in this situation
like say it had gotten to this place of
the roof deal one of us wants to go on
our own and the other wants to stay a
barstool and take this deal like what
what we're not even that which one which
pathway to other wanted you and I were
in a very similar situation when our
show the morning breath got canceled
that Verizon we didn't have a choice we
couldn't stay a Verizon so it was made
for us and at the end of the day because
we're sisters we wouldn't have split up
like that's just not how we were raised
like we have to do everything together
so it was probably
to be whatever you wanted to do cuz
you're smarter than me and I would have
just said yes but if I was like alone or
I was if I was in this position I don't
know because when I was listening to
Alex I was like you know there's so many
benefits of being a parcel and Dave was
incredibly amenable in the negotiations
like when he offered them five hundred
thousand and then more points on merch
and alcohol like I probably would have
taken that good deal but I have an agent
I have lawyers like that's the way you
do business outside a bar stool because
bar stool is its own like incubator of
weirdness but outside a bar stool just
like in podcasting you have a lawyer you
have a business manager you have a team
of agents like that's how it works
that's what we both have so I don't
fault Sofia for like surrounding herself
with those types of people because
that's what podcasters do every
successful podcaster I know has a full
team of people I'm just saying that
right and I know it's been made to seem
like Sofia and her demands were so crazy
and I do think there's two things
happening one like she was just trying
to get more and more and more maybe
because she wanted to get them to a
point of not even having a deal so that
they wouldn't have a choice but to go
out on their own but also like Sofia
brought in William Morris WME and like
those are our agents and they do deals
for us all the time and like they ask
for things that we would never think to
ask for ourselves but that are actually
so important and like really raise the
quality of your contract so I don't
think that they came in and just started
asking for outlandish stuff like they've
never done a deal for us where they're
just putting things in that don't
actually benefit us in the long run yes
I could see how they would appear to be
outlandish in bar stool world where
nobody has an agent they all just
negotiate themselves and like certain
things that they probably WME like
brought up to bars so I had never been
brought up before but that's because
that's like the type of atmosphere
they've successfully created it's like
everyone who works there is just onboard
they want to fight the good fight like
they believe in the message of bar stool
and that's great but when you get an
agent they're like well this is not how
things are done for other podcast
networks so right I don't know it's like
I can't identify why I feel the way that
I feel and part of me just like aches
for Sophia and I think it might just be
because like I have been cancelled and
sometimes I just I just automatically
sided with the person who got cancelled
because it's never what people think and
at the end of the day I know people who
are huge fans of the podcast were like
devastated about this break and I get
then I respect
that but that at the end of the day like
is it worth bullying someone online
is it worth someone trying to ruin
someone's life just because you're upset
about a podcast like I personally just
don't think so so I think part of me is
always just gonna side with the underdog
because I have been the underdog but at
the end of the day like I probably would
have taken the rooftop deal yeah and I
think at the end of the day they should
have prioritized being together like the
mentality especially Sophia like knowing
now what we know which is that Alex did
a lot of the owl of the editing and a
lot of it was on Alex's back and Sophia
brought so much like personality to the
show but when it comes to like who can
do this show on their own it's really
Alex so like Sophie had to be like a
little bit more mean about to what Alex
wanted and if I were Sophia it would
have been like I would rather be back at
bar stool than have no show at all and
she chose to fold instead of make it
work and when now she wants to make it
work - scooter bra and stuff we need to
talk about it's too little too late alex
has already made the very difficult
decision to put the show on her back
alone made that public already like you
don't go back on that and also once you
decide oh wow I just went from having
said I just went from having 3% of call
her daddy to 50% of call dairy - a
hundred percent of call her daddy why am
I gonna give that up again when I just
realized within myself that I can do
this and she can by the way I think the
show the numbers will women his star she
door she's a star she can do it I think
this might be the beginning of something
like even bigger for her it'll go it's
gonna be either something bigger or
it'll always be call her daddy without
Sophia but I do think that she has the
stuff to be like a female Howard Stern I
completely agree I think she's gonna be
fine the show's gonna be fine it's
probably gonna be better than it ever
was just because of the press this story
got and now so many people are just
tuning in because they're curious and
they'll stay there because she's
hilarious and she's beautiful and she's
charismatic and she has you know
uniqueness nerve and talent like she'll
be fine ya know in the next episode and
in the next few are gonna be like their
biggest episodes yet but let's talk in
six months like I think she'll be fine
in six months but that will be the real
determining factor right now the whole
world is invested in this story like of
course Wednesday's episode is gonna be
like no she'll be fun from
from the video it was very clear to me
that Alex's number-one priority is the
podcast and listeners like and that's
really if you're gonna launch a
successful podcast that has to be your
goal it can't be money fame stardom like
it really has to be like the content and
the community and if you don't focus on
that like you're not gonna succeed so I
like had so much faith in Alex after
watching the video because I feel like
her priorities aren't check of course
she needs to look out for number one
like and herself paid of course but her
real it really came through that like
her number one priority and her focus on
in this whole thing is just getting a
good podcast out getting episodes
churned out on time edited properly
getting involved with the community like
making sure the listeners are taken care
of and to me that's what that makes a
good podcaster I agree and now I think
the place where she didn't completely
drag Sofie I didn't think at all um but
the things that Sofia if she cares would
need to answer for is like this feeling
of like Lena she never wanted the deal
to work out in the first place yet every
time Alex would explain like what Sofia
was working towards they were actually
legitimate deal points and I think
Sophia and her posse wound up getting
Alex an incredible deal by doing all of
that negotiating so I think that Sofia
just needs some like if she wanted to if
she cared to to make a video and explain
like what she was trying to do like yeah
they keep saying she would do this and
then she wanted that explain what those
things were because the few explanations
we got from Alex seemed like you had
very legitimate points yes and at the
end of the day all of her crazy like
moving the goalposts got Alex she didn't
realize she was doing it at the time but
she really just got Alex a better deal
the deal she got Alex Peter Nelson's
deal the deal of a 100 percent for
herself right so okay so now yesterday
Dave shared that Scooter Braun called
Erica asking for this is paraphrasing
but pretty much asking to let Sophia
back in 50 percent of call her daddy
I guess who tur Braun is a friend of
Peter Nelson's and he thought like
calling in the big dogs
this favor would get her her job back he
must be feeling horrible well what was
interesting was that Scooter Braun
responded and was like this is actually
not what happened
and then he deleted his tweets
so like I wasn't sure if we should
believe it cuz if you delete something
does that mean it's not true and then
Scooter Braun called Dave directly and
Dave said he does not want to be a part
of this drama I promised him I would
like leave his name out of my mouth for
the remainder of this so I don't really
know if what um
if what scooters called the CEO of
Barstow form was about Sophia I mean I
could see how it would be like friend of
Peter Nelson hey you're more famous than
me can you hook it up I need your help
and you would think that like Dave would
like kowtow to like manager to the Stars
Scooter Braun but that's why I [ __ ]
love Dave he's like I'm tweeting this
later Brown called scooter Bronco like
that's why you psychotic like if scooter
bruh I'm called me like I would shut the
[ __ ] up and like do whatever he said you
know cuz I'm a loser and I have no
principles but like I love that even
though it's not for everyone like I love
that dave has principles and he's like
no I'm [ __ ] tweeting this yeah it was
really funny I am impressed with suit
man that he's friends a skier Braun
though I know like the more I hear about
suit man the more like mm-hmm
eligible Harvard I just hate suit man as
much as the world does but maybe that's
my inherent you know need to nurture
people who are being cancelled like
maybe that's inside me or maybe I truly
believe like he was just trying to help
his friend his girlfriend and their
friend like get a better deal on their
amazing podcast I don't know but either
way I just refused to blame it all on
one man I agree but I do feel like in
watching Alex's video like I was putting
myself in Sofie issues and I feel like
she got to a place where the bar stool
deal was good and she felt like she had
to choose between like bar stool and
Dave and suit man and like
industry-standard and there was no way
there was no there like and I know if
she's choosing a man over her
relationship but like they're in a very
serious relationship like there was no
way that she was gonna choose Dave over
her boyfriend it wasn't a matter of
choosing Alex over suit man it was
choosing right date you know yeah
honestly the vibe that I got was just
like Sofia did not want to be a parcel
anymore yeah I agree but like her
dislike of barsoom needed to be less
than her love of working
Alex right you you really hit the nail
on the head when if their priority the
whole time had been presenting a united
front regardless of whether they were
disagreeing internally like they just
needed to present a united front to both
the industry and bar stool to get what
they wanted I'm in the minute that they
showed the world that like they were
divided like that was the beginning of
the end a hundred percent and you know
what I completely understand also though
Alex going off on her own like Sophia
and her of course posse of lawyers and
agents are [ __ ] with Alex's money now
and at that point it's like okay you
might ruin this deal I'm going to snatch
it like no and that's why this whole
situation so frustrating I don't fault
anyone like I think everyone really did
what they thought was best for their
career for their lives like I I think
what Dave did was very respectful like
he gave the girls a great deal and kept
agreeing to their list of demands I
thought Alex eventually taking the deal
was what she thought was best
I think Sofia holding out was what she
thought was best like I don't think
anybody intentionally crossed anyone
here no but sometimes a bad deal
is better than no deal and that would be
like right now yeah because Alex laugh
is saying that the bad deal is better
than no deal I don't know or is no deal
is better than a bad deal I think it's a
bad deal is better than no deal I think
that's the same I don't know sometimes I
think if no deal is better than a bad
deal I've I've had some bad but then you
get nothing like hold on let me look it
up bad deal yeah but sometimes what you
get from a bad deal isn't worth your
time and energy and happiness that you
put into it
okay Harvard politics says no deal is
better than a bad deal yeah I agree
okay well I the opposite for this yeah
actually it's agree yeah it wasn't a no
deal is a great deal for Sophia for Alex
for Alex yeah I mean this whole thing
just makes me sad like they're really
good friends their roommates like what
is going on with the apartment like I'm
sure they're quarantined elsewhere but
like what are they gonna do about rent
that's what I really needed the video to
address like the logistics of like
breaking up with your best friend who's
also your roommate oh no I feel like
that's pretty simple because um now alex
is a millionaire and she can go get a
new place and also like Sophia could
like live a suit man for a little bit
while they work it out I'm concerned but
so they're still gonna pay rent oh maybe
one of them will keep the apartment
maybe Alex I think Alex will move out
and with her new paycheck um but my
concern is what is Sophia gonna do for
work yeah I mean she has to 800,000
followers and she's losing followers but
after all this is done she'll have
around 800,000 followers and that is a
career whether you like it or not like
you can make a living off of that
whether or not she wants to dive into
like launching another podcast and being
a full-time influencer I don't know like
is her life with soo-man and off like
sometimes love is all you really need
yeah when you're dating a rich man
that's true well I hope that he keeps
his job and that they stay together yeah
and this just has been so crazy to me
what the craziest part is like seeing
people on like Twitter and and even in
the toast Facebook groups being like I
know Alex's sisters roommates brothers
mother and she said yes he she said
Peter Nelson's getting tired it's like
you don't know anything ya know and I
think that if Peter Nelson was gonna get
fired it would have already happened cuz
now like things are pretty quiet and
maybe Sophia won't put out a video just
because she wants them to remain quiet
you know yeah and she just wants it all
to end I know what that feeling is like
you just want everyone to stop talking
about you yeah and if she like I mean
obviously people are gonna talk about
the next episode but then this saga will
have come to an end right and when and
if she releases a video it just trudges
up the news cycle and then responds to
that yeah starts playing more videos and
I understand like wanting to clear your
name but sometimes like it's just not
worth it yeah I'm a terrible position to
be in
yeah so I actually don't think we're
gonna get um a statement from her
because also I don't think Alex was
really like lying or leaning or I don't
think her video was biased I thought it
was very fair I thought it was fair - I
think Alex did a good job of speaking
for Sophia up until a point um and then
there's like a few things that Sophia
could clarify but it I don't think that
worth it for her to bring it back up
well I have loved recapping this story
like I love podcast news I'm so sorry
that like a friendship was broken in the
midst but like I just I'm loving you
know podcasts being top priority in the
new cycle because we deserve respect
yeah I agree I think this really took
the whole podcast world by storm it
showed that there is a podcast world
people are interested in it and these
girls are just so interesting honestly I
think you and I should split up because
like we need that kind of press we do
need that kind of press but we need
someone who would be like narrating it
may be snatcher being like oh my god
emergency press conference like oh yeah
we would need like a days yeah she'll be
like I offered them a better deal on my
roof and they just to not take it no
that's what we were doing on the roof we
beat this horse into the ground yeah
well let you know I'm excited to listen
to Alex's episode me too okay next story
another shocker Riverdale's cole sprouse
and lily reinhard have split again
sources say there's some messy like I
don't I I used to like read a headline
about whether or not they were broken up
or getting back together and I would
feel something you know I feel nothing
I'm flat line I don't give a [ __ ] when
you're like in the news so much like we
broke up Brian Austin Green Megan Fox
Kelly like that whole like anyway we're
together we're not like I'm done you
lost me after to fake breakups like I'm
officially out it's gonna be a no for me
what this says to me it's like he's
always going into haters like stop
talking meta stop saying we broke up we
didn't break up we're together and now
like this official breakup that's
literally everywhere it's not just
rumors it's like reported as real news
um it just goes to show that all those
other rumors were true you know by the
way totally like when he wrote his whole
Instagram letter about like he not
tolerating negative comments like
because people were saying he was like
with kaya Gerber or something I don't
know but this now today makes me think
all of that was true yeah and you know
what when you are so private about where
your relationship which everyone is
entitled to some people like love to
Instagram story everything about their
really
ship and let people in but when you
don't like I stopped caring like I just
don't really feel and maybe it's also
because I stopped watching Riverdale so
I can never got to see their chemistry
anymore like I just easier to people I
genuinely don't care about um yeah I've
already like made I've what's the word
I've come to terms with the fact that
they're like not OTP because OTP doesn't
keep breaking up and getting back
together and so now having this
confirmation like I feel prepared for
the news yeah I don't know if I ever
thought they were OTP because they just
seemed so different to me and I felt
like in a lot of ways like Lily was
becoming unmeet by the way and I know
nothing about them I just felt like Lily
was becoming the girlfriend that he
needed because he's so weird in
particular that's just the vibe that I
get and I just feel like she needs she's
me free she's the kind of particular to
though but I just feel like he was like
in charge of the particular era T's do
you know any man
yeah I'm just worried now because I
really like bug-head as a couple on the
show mostly because it leaves both of
them too busy to bother Archie and
Veronica who I ship more than anything
barchi and so now that they're broken up
in real life I feel like writer Ross
might break them up on the show because
like it's not believable anymore he goes
by like what's going on like even
Veronica started dating um melted Jean
yeah when they were dating until like
now is Betty single I just see her going
after Archie and that's just like not
gonna work for my barchi stand hood by
the way that is so true and I think
writer to Ross is a genius on many
fronts but one because he leads into
real life we've said here many times
like what makes a great franchise it's
true chemistry and that leads me to
something I wanted to talk about later
which is normal people watch talk about
oh you didn't I watched the first five
episodes because I'm you I heard
actually great things and I read the
book and I didn't love the book but I
heard and the show is better than the
book I would say like 75% of why I
thought the show was so fantastic was
because Mary Anne and I could canal
panel touch crazy chemistry like I felt
like sometimes I was watching porn like
they had to I've been [ __ ] in real
life like there's no way you can have
chemistry
I'm sorry neither of them are that good
of actors like they had to have had
something in real life because there was
this
electricity between them Wow okay I look
forward to hearing your full recap you
have a lot of thoughts on normal people
next story Grimes and Elon Musk changed
their baby's name from what it was
before to comply with the law
Grimes must have changed their baby
boy's name the misanthropic singer said
after it failed to comply with
California law the 32 year old new mom
shared the news on Instagram after a
follower asked her why what the baby's
new name was she answered with a
different name as confusing to read
Roman numerals looks better tbh
she said she removed the numbers to
conform to California law you're only
allowed to have one - in your name
according to California State so that's
why her - - name was not going to work
no no no I think it's that they had the
numbers 12 they had one - at 12 in the
first name but you can't have numbers in
a name so they changed it to XII which
is 12 in Roman numeral but I also heard
of that something to do with the number
of dashes huh
that's what I read interesting this is
like crazy it's like I know I mean this
is just like when you're such an artist
you don't think about the logistics of
the law you know you're no can't be held
back by those types of like arbitrary
laws you know totally understand how
this happened the law and the art just
do not mix no because you know what they
say art is just lawlessness yeah the BA
is reason free from art you did not just
quote that yes that was a great quote
what is it law is free from resilience
yeah I think so
or yeah something or love hold on let me
Google of the way the professor in
Legally Blonde says it from passion the
law that's such an iconic scene in
Legally Blonde
and then that tall guy he won't forget
her books at the library like he was a
real hero honestly that's what she was
saying passion is art the BA is reason
for you from art it's so [ __ ] true
like
honestly I'm making that my Instagram I
oh that's so funny hold on give me one
second
should do it on Claude with no job or
girl with no job I think job like I
think a wider audience meets generally
every girl with no job one the everyday
implications of this phrase like it's
his one reason free from period or no
period I think no period like open-ended
is it a sentence is it a complete
sentence or is right it's up to
interpretation right saved oh my god
that is so [ __ ] funny
Claudia that's beautiful thank you for
him ID me everyone please make sure you
pre-ordered my comedy special it is
available for pre-order on iTunes it is
$12.99 you can click the link in my bio
girl with no job you can also take a
look at my new Instagram bio while
you're there head over to iTunes buy it
support please I'm an up-and-coming
comedian and I could use the support of
my fellow humanitarians love it ok you
ready for our next story
I love how loved it has become away for
you be like cool shut the [ __ ] up we're
moving hot it's just like hard on zoom
to you know to like the way that we used
to just like filter out of conversations
like that would require a lot of talking
on top of each other so it's very like
calling response on zoom and I know it
sounds like I'm being short but I am
short I understand you know mm-hmm
because we could keep going back and
forth like this but then it's just like
no you can move on we need struck me on
it love it love it
ok ready for our next story I love it
Taylor Swift hypes killing Eve cover of
her song but who is Jack's leopard the
Queen of Pop took to social media on
Sunday night to express excitement over
her song look what you made me do
appearing the psycho psycho thriller
series though not perform my Swift
herself rather an unknown group Jack
leopards and the dolphin Club was
credited with the soundtrack recording
she tweeted that she's very stoked that
the band covered her song but the fact
that there is no historical record of
this musical group having ever existed
outside the BBC series and that Niles
Taj Berg the songwriting student named
Swift used on Calvin Harris
this is what you came for is credited on
the soundtrack has inspired the latest
raging Twitter conspiracy among
Swifties it's not a conspiracy theory
it's 100% true Taylor Swift pseudonym
Nile ska Berg which is like a student
and she uses it's listed as one of the
producers the album cover and the the
bands logo is the picture of a kid and
it's a picture of her brother Austin
Swift it's like a famous picture well
not famous but it's like a Swifties no
the picture he's wearing a striped shirt
it's 100% her it's not a theory it's
true RSK fifties now and it makes sense
because this is a song that she released
when she was under a big machine so she
isn't able to rerelease and rerecord her
old music until November of 2020 so
until then she has to get creative and
this is how she got creative I think
it's Jack Antonoff and maybe her brother
singing on it maybe it has nothing to do
with her brother but Jack Antonoff is
involved she definitely produced it but
because she is not really involved it's
some roundabout way of like cutting big
machine out of a picture completely
which is pretty smart yeah that is
pretty smart loop pulse season yeah
she's getting creative I mean she's
boarding quarantine and this shows it
yeah and like will for her brother he'll
probably make some good my way yeah he's
a cutie like I need I mean one of my
friends to date him that's like my aunt
I think yeah good luck yeah okay ready
for our next story love it real houses
Beverly Hills star Garcelle buboes
eldest son ties the knot in a little
white chapel ceremony ourselves Oh is
officially a mother-in-law the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills star
announced on Sunday that her eldest son
Oliver Saunders tied the knot with his
fiancee Sam amid the corona virus
pandemic
congratulations Oliver and Sam welcome
to the family she wrote on Instagram
alongside three photos including
including a smiling shot of Oliver and
Sam and the couple standing with their
children who bow also shared a snap of
the newlyweds had a little Whitechapel
where they stood next to one another in
front of a walk-up window and under a
sign that reads the little white wedding
chapel drive through with them oh that
is so cute I love Garcelle any simcha
for her as a simcha for the world so I'm
just wishing her and her family a
lifetime of happiness I
we agree and I love a chapel wedding in
these foreign times like I love people
who are getting creative and then are
still choosing to get married in
different sorts of ways and I I love it
yeah me and Ben were having this
conversation um like if we were in this
position what would we do and I what I
said and I think I really meant it is I
would definitely get married legally so
like go to a little white chapel or just
go to City Hall or whatever's open um
just so I didn't have to like delay the
start of my marriage but then after like
a year I would throw a mighty like a
[ __ ] rager yeah I agree with that
that's what I would do great well maybe
we could still throw a rager anyway oh
no I'm in you know I just can't wait for
that day cannot wait to be raging like
Bloc Party go to the club I don't care
I'm staying out to the break of John
give me ecstasy like I'll do anything
those we're the five stories so you
don't know them and now you do um so
let's dive into our TV recap segment I
have so many things but let's talk about
normal people first since we both
started and I won't spoil it for you but
you read the book and it's pretty much
it really is true to the book down to
conversations and and they haven't added
like little fires everywhere just like
complete storylines that didn't exist
like everything is pretty much by the
book yeah I mean I didn't know what it
was about it just came very highly
recommended to me so when I put it on I
thought it was like an Irish high school
drama I like Irish Riverdale and I was
so excited and then like after the third
episode there in college which I just
thought was so annoying and I get that
it takes it takes a like the story is
reflected in like a long period of time
but I just wanted more like high school
dance drama like I never got to see her
like graduate you know ya know it's and
also like it's just so crazy like their
high school scenes are so sad because
she was such a pariah in high school
social pariah but then you go to college
and it just it's such it's so [ __ ]
true like the people who are not so my
true [ __ ] thrived in college and like
you look
in high school and the soccer in his
little short-shorts you're like oh my
god that's the hobby of all hotties blog
that it's rugby then sitting in the
college classroom it's like why would I
look at him no so true like it's like
you're your social currency like changes
overnight and people don't know how to
exchange the currency no and it's like
high school is all about looks and
really college is all about your
personality it's crazy it's like people
just get to college maybe because it's
all the people who like hated high
school being about looks so they're just
deciding like we're gonna value people
for who they are not what they look like
you know it's a beautiful thing no it's
a beautiful thing but it's a crazy
phenomenon like I'm a guy graduating
high school I feel so cool cuz he's like
captain of the rugby team and then he
goes to college and he gives a [ __ ]
about him yeah I hated that Maryann kept
referring to herself as ugly in high
school because she just grad her bangs
like she was exactly the same she was
always a pretty girl um to me like the
best part of the show was the two of
them together it was also the worst part
of the show because this is like what
this show should have been called when
two introverts fall in love because they
just couldn't properly communicate in so
many of like their Tiff's like when when
she thought he was breaking up with her
for the summer and he was just asking to
move in like and they ended up breaking
up for a whole year just because of the
miscommunication like that was
infuriating so seeing them together
attempt to communicate was the worst
part of the show but them together was
the best part of the show because they
had this real off air and on-air
chemistry like it was so palpable I
thought they were great together like I
just wanted them to keep [ __ ] like it
was really a porno Oh
and so when I'm watching a show I like
can't follow all the people on Instagram
I don't want to spoil it so the second
it's over I could always go on Instagram
and like Google and see what happened
and there was like a big scandal that
like someone put together a compilation
like a 20 minute video of all their sex
scenes and put it on pornhub and Netflix
and everyone like had to get involved
and getting it taken down because it's
such a like a disgrace to their artwork
you know yeah but they really like was
super poorni like at first I was
surprised that we were getting like high
school and nipple from her I was like oh
wow like I'm like I'm not mad about it
but that's just interesting like usually
we just like cut above in it whatever
hmm I got comfortable with the nipple
like so excited so here for it and then
like we just see his penis no oh
and I know it's such a double standard
to like not really win sent a nipple but
then like see a penis and like die but
that's just like the standard of the
industry it's like you don't see penises
no but I also haven't seen vagina yet so
I saw I don't know if I'm gonna see it
um I'm not gonna see it so actually yeah
you do see her Bush like twice okay so I
just haven't seen bad yet and I thought
we were just like an only nipple show
and then like there was just a scene of
them laying and it's not like his penis
needed to be out but like they chose her
to be out and I was just really shook
and again here for it like do yours lady
I just when I was reading the book I
just never said like and you're gonna
see his pieces no I know it's it's it
shouldn't be so jarring because like we
see women's bodies on TV all the time
but like seeing a penis it's just like
it's honestly like it's it's like an
assault on the eyes like it's just you
not expecting it it's so like pointy and
you're just like well no it's like
sometimes they always want to show like
tits and vagina and sometimes in order
to show the vagina like you have to
skirt around the penis and and then they
do it and they always turn around so
like just to see like the pieces like in
its natural environment like when nobody
like was needed to see it you know like
it wasn't
collateral damage you know I understand
like we have been so trained by the
patriarchy just like skirt around the
penis and so for them to have showed it
to us in a scene where it wasn't
necessarily even a factor like it wasn't
they were just laying on the bed I know
what you mean it's very shocking like no
one's dying woke up that morning and
said hey I think I mean the game of
Thrones entire series there was one
penis when Aria goes backstage yeah and
it like took the world by storm even
though we seen that big of a deal like
just show the penis ya know and I guess
it's what normal people are trying to do
it's like normal people have penises
yeah they do and so the show I mean the
ending like I guess it's up to
interpretation because when I put it up
my Instagram story
I got like so many people who were like
it means this and then other people were
what do you say I tapped through because
there's a spoiler alert and just in case
but then I heard that endings the same
as the books so what do you so boiler
alert I thought that the ending there
they're not together anymore
um they're not gonna be together in the
future was like they both serve the
purpose for each other of like he kind
of got her out of this very dark place
she like showed him what love is and
they both like they serve their purpose
for one another and they can go on with
their lives and use what they learned in
this relationship in the future and some
people thought that like it was left
open that they're gonna get back
together when he comes back to New York
um I just when I watch it I just felt
like this makes no sense like they were
genuinely in love like she didn't really
have anything holding her back in
Ireland like why couldn't she go with
him
they were so in love like it just didn't
make sense to me
yeah and that's pretty much how the book
ends too but just the way that I read it
was like they're they're meant for each
other they're going to end up together
they're always on and off to you to like
life circumstances this is just another
off period but like I see them being
together in the end but he's gonna go
and like do his thing um you know cuz
he's not gonna like just give up a great
opportunity for her but she'll be there
for him when he gets back even if she's
in another relationship like you know it
they'll break up and they'll get back
together because that's just what they
do yeah I just wish there was more like
um of a concrete answer like I hate when
people leave things open to
interpretation like just tell me what
the [ __ ] happened yeah I can understand
that how that's frustrating but when I
read in the book I just didn't really
care I was over it ya know by the end I
was like kind of over and it was really
frustrating to see them like just not be
able to get it together yeah that is
really always frustrating especially in
a show like that was kind of like that
movie we watch love Rosie oh okay so it
reminded me of love Rosie so much maybe
it was because it was like both injera
but like the whole vibe was so similar
like they kept missing each other they
were definitely the right people for
each other they were on cobblestone
streets in Europe it gave me so much
love Rosie babe yeah I feel that when
you read that sort of story in a book
though it's not as annoying as when you
watch it in the show that's possible it
was like exhausting in the show yeah I'm
only halfway through so I'll let you
know what I think about the rest of it
tomorrow just wanna give a book update
cuz that's what I've been doing reading
I finished the southern book clubs guide
to slaying vampires and
[ __ ] weird and so creepy and gross at
times but if you're into like weird
stuff which a lot of people are um I
would recommend it it was a fun one it
was an easy read i multiplied I did not
choose it for the redheads you guys
would have murdered me um and then I
also started the most fun we ever had by
Claire Lombardo it's really long but so
far it's really cute and I'm just like
taking my time with it and enjoying it
so that's out on that yeah um so for me
I watched so much [ __ ] TV and it was
really the weekend of Hulu like I didn't
get off Hulu I watched Dave which is all
on Hulu it was like short and sweet Ben
really liked it it was funny um it's one
of those shows where it's like you like
everything about the show except the
main character like Dave it's just so
[ __ ] annoying and he thinks that he's
the greatest rapper of all time and he's
just that he's funny got the one with um
that guy lil Dicky yes yeah I took about
him he plays a little Dicky his name is
Dave it's all about like him becoming a
rapper I'm sure like some of the stories
are definitely rooted in fact it's just
it's infuriating to watch like he's so
annoying and he just makes the worst
decisions that's really annoying but
they have so many famous people on it
like Kourtney Kardashian Charlamagne was
like they went to The Breakfast Club
like it was cool to see so many like
real rappers and celebrities but it was
just infuriating Dan okay I'm not gonna
watch out I had no plans to go sorry
that you watched you in for of working
moms and it was fine like it was just it
got me through the day it was fine it
wasn't amazing I just liked the show it
was fine that's all I should say but
what I really came on this show this
morning to talk about was the handmade
sale because I started I started one
episode and I was like you know what I'm
not gonna watch this it gave me such a
pit like like the show it's just about
this like [ __ ] up cult and obviously
aches at your heart and so I wasn't
gonna watch it anymore but something
just kept like I kept thinking like I
wonder what Gene's doing like I just I
really wanted to know more so I made the
decision to watch a couple episodes last
night then came in around the fifth
episode and it was such a mistake to let
him watch with me because I just find it
annoying when people ask so many
questions so before we watch I gave him
like the whole she feel like they're in
this cold they took over the country
blah blah then is just getting lost in
the minutiae of the cult he's like well
how did they move into this house if
they were in a cult I'm like it doesn't
matter like he was just being so
specific
like not even about the storyline just
about like the logistics that have a
cult
took over which they don't tell you like
it was just I'm like then we don't know
shut the [ __ ] up he was bothering me so
much and now he was he is like a very
sensitive soul
you know so he couldn't sleep all night
because it's such a [ __ ] up show and
he literally like came in this morning
he was like I can't believe you made me
watch that show it broke my spirit okay
now I have a question for you like why
did you were you even tempted to watch
one episode like if I've had to think of
like the least you show I could think of
in the universe it would be The
Handmaid's Tale I know in my anxiety and
like my battle with mental health is so
bad in quarantine like I really
shouldn't watch it but I'm just like I'm
kind of intrigued and I watched it
because I want something that I can be
invested in like I'm on a 30-minute show
Dave working mom it's nothing it's like
silly and this is definitely like a
commentary on something I can't figure
out what it is that it's about it's
based on a book that was written in the
80s so a lot of people want to say it's
like a commentary on like the current
climate around women's reproductive
issues cuz the whole thing is like you
joined the cult and the fertile women
like have to give birth for all the
masters it's so [ __ ] up like so but
this was written in the 80s and I'm not
getting that vibe a lot of people are
telling me that it's a commentary on
like an extreme version of Amish and
polygamy cult I don't know Ben came up
with a theory now it's definitely wrong
but it really made you think and I think
that's why he was so taken by it cuz
like you would think whatever you want
the woman who wrote it said that like
everything that happens in the show has
happened in history at least once so
it's like a culmination of all the most
[ __ ] up things happening in history
but Ben really I think he knows what the
show is a representation I mean it
sounded silly at first okay so let me
just tell you what the cult is before if
you're gonna watch a show like maybe you
don't listen but I'm not spoiling
anything the whole show is like back to
traditional the cult is like traditional
values the men are in charge and the
women live at home and just our birthing
out children but a lot of the powerful
women are barren and so they have the
handmaids which are basically like all
the fertile young women who give birth
and basically get raped once a month by
the commander's in order to get them
pregnant and then they put they get the
girls pregnant and they pretend like
it's the wives kid when it's not it's
the handmaids kid but they give up all
it's just it's all about reproductive
rights so Ben really feels like this is
a commentary
like puppy mills and breeders and I was
like you're insane but then the more
that I thought about it like they make
these dogs like give birth and then they
take the dogs away and give them to
different families which is like
essentially what happens in The
Handmaid's down and I know it's like
crazy but like I kind of felt it and
it's like The Handmaid's are like
servants like they can't go or do
anything without being told what to do
they have to they can only walk that's
like their one activity that's what dogs
do damn yeah no it's definitely like nah
it's like not the worst thing it's not
the stupidest thing he's ever said no I
know so I need to do more research cuz
to me like the show is so [ __ ] up and
it's not it never happened it's not like
a retelling of history so why does this
fake story need to be told it's so
[ __ ] up but that's like so many shows
that I don't watch like Westworld know
but this one is so black mare yeah I
guess but to me like this one is so
painful to watch more so than anything
I've ever watched and it deals with such
like real issue on their games in the
most unethical way like I just don't
know why this story is necessary like
it's really upsetting Hunger Games but I
am gonna keep watching it because I'm so
curious but you know I don't live for
Elisabeth Moss and I don't know if she
can really carry the show I mean I guess
she does cuz it's a successful show that
has multiple seasons but I just don't
like live for her I understand that yeah
and then there's just like you know the
huge elephant in the room right the
Scientology Co elephant right it's like
Elisabeth Moss is a very involved
Scientologist which many have likened to
a cult and she's just like here playing
this role of like a cult it's just it's
a little too on the nose for me
interesting well I look forward to
hearing your recaps cuz I won't be
watching no don't watch like I literally
now that olivia is a mom i text her
yesterday I'm like you have to promise
me you are never going to watch
Handmaid's Tale she's like I'm literally
never gonna watch it don't worry it's
just so painful and I'm not even a mom
like but just seeing these hand mates
like give birth to babies and then
having to like go back to their chambers
it's awful yeah that's really sad
it's a terrible show please never watch
it but I'm to MTD I will not be watching
it you don't have to worry about me and
if you have a soul that needs to be
protected please don't watch this show
okay
very care well I think that's all she
wrote right yeah oh wait let me see she
just texted oh she said she's dead oh
thank god okay cool well thanks guys for
listening is short week this week which
is awesome
and we'll see tomorrow and just always
remember that laws reason free from
passion and art which is also the same
thing as passion please pre-order my
comedy special now available on iTunes
disgraced Queen you can just search
Claudia out try to come right up thank
you so much for the support and thank
you so much for listening to the morning
to us a millennial Morning Show where we
go live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so every
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
set spotify itunes stitcher public video
i have radio cast box all the places so
ever you listen to podcast find us
somewhere nito's and leave a five star
review about a beautiful stunning and
smart we are we love you guys very much
we'll see you tomorrow i